thank you
C plus plus is one of the oldest
programming languages and is still going
strong more than 37 years after it first
appear on the scene
according to the tiobe index C plus plus
lies at the fourth position in terms of
popularity of programming languages but
why is it still so popular well there
are numerous reasons for that like C
plus plus has a big community of users
and professionals it is one of the most
efficient and fastest languages and is
widely used by competitive programmers
for its execution speed
even for game development C plus plus is
preferred because of the cross-platform
portability faster execution and CPU
architecture support
furthermore many current systems and
programs are already developed in C plus
and those systems must be maintained and
writing the same code again in some
other language will not solve the
problem and it would be a tedious task
therefore C plus plus is used in all
those circumstances
many other programming languages like
including C sharp and Java have been
influenced by C plus plus and is still
used in various applications or software
for example Spotify Amazon Bloomberg and
YouTube these are few examples of that
according to zapier.com C plus plus
developers in the United States earn an
average of 106
000 and 28 dollars per year this
obviously highlights the importance for
you to brush up your XC plus expertise
and this video will help you with that
so in this video on C plus plus full
course you will learn all about C plus
plus you will start with what C plus
plus programming is where it is used
applications of C plus plus and other
basic C plus plus programming topics
like string if else statements functions
data types and variables
after that we will cover some
intermediate topics like call by value
and call by reference in Z Plus
recursion arrays header files pointers
classes in C plus plus Etc
you will also learn how to download and
use Ides for C plus plus towards the end
we will understand some Advanced topics
like STL C plus plus GUI and some
interview questions that will help you
in the interview preparation
and finally we will cover some crucial
projects in C plus plus that will help
you understand C plus plus programming
in a better way I can assure you that
all your C plus programming questions
and doubts will be clarified by the end
of this video so without further Ado
let's start with this exciting video on
C plus plus full course but before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and press the Bell icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learned hey everyone welcome back to
another video session by simply learn in
this session on C plus plus full course
for beginners we will be learning
different concepts and topics of C plus
plus
this video tutorial will help in
learning and understanding the C plus
programming language in both theoretical
and practical way by doing some Hands-On
examples
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so we'll start with the introduction to
C plus plus programming language and how
to download and install C plus plus in
Windows then we will start with the
force programming C plus plus along with
the terms like variables types then the
concepts like if else statements Loops
functions in C plus plus call by value
call by reference and friend function
then we will cover topics like arrays
pointers in C plus plus this pointer
references and memory management we will
also learn about sorting in C plus
after that we will move on to object
oriented programming topics like classes
in C plus plus oops Concepts Etc and
after that we will move on to topics
like vectors in C plus plus STL that is
standard template library and in the end
we'll also learn to make some projects
in C plus
so without further Ado let's get started
so let's start with the introduction to
C plus plus programming
C plus plus is a popular programming
language introduced by John strowstrup
in the year 1979. the aim was to make a
dynamic language that is efficient and
has some additional features to see
initially it was called C with classes
as it was an extension to C language but
later renamed as C plus plus
it is general purpose case sensitive
language and it is called pre-compiled
language because it converts the source
code directly to the machine
understandable code
it is an intermediate level language
because it contains both features of
high level and low level language
C plus plus supports the features of
object oriented language like
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
Etc it also supports procedural
programming and functional programming
as well
welcome to this video where we'll be
telling you how you can install C plus
on vs code and Dev C plus plus after we
are done with the installation we'll
also learn how to run a program on both
of these code editors so we'll start
with Visual Studio code
to download vs code let's go to Google
and search for visual studio code or vs
code
we'll click on this first link
this is the official web page for
downloading the visual studio code
and we'll now click on this download for
Windows Blue Button
and now we'll click on download now
here it is getting download and
as you can see
thanks for downloading Visual Studio
code for Windows
once we are done with the download we
can click on this open folder
here it is
now we need to install this file so
we'll double click on this file
and this is a set of wizard
we'll click on this I accept the
agreement
and we'll click on next
as we have accepted the licensing
agreement now we can select our
destination folder or we can leave it as
it is but make sure there must be 293.2
MB of free space on that particular disk
space
now
we'll click on next
here we can again click on X there is no
need to change over here
and now
you can click on this create a desktop
icon button or anyone else as per your
choice
now we'll click on next
and now we'll click finally on install
it is getting installed it will take
some time
now we can click on this finish button
launch Visual Studio we have marked it
it is already marked so when we click on
this finish button it will launch the
visual studio code
so as we can see this is the visual
studio code
so as we have installed vs code now we
have to configure it so that the C plus
plus programs can run in this code
editor
so in order to do that we need to add
some extensions so we'll click on this
extensions button
now here we will write code Runner
extension we'll write code Runner
and this is extension
when click on this install
and it is getting installed
here are some instructions we can click
on Control Plus alt plus n
or press F1 and then select type run
code but we'll deal with that later
now
we'll add another extension that is C
slash C plus plus
here it is a
we'll click on this install
here we can see downloading Visual
Studio Windows debugger
it is getting installed and I think it
is installed now
so as we have added both the extensions
so let's move on and do a program of C
plus plus in this code editor
we can Define strings as a collection or
group of characters
it is basically used to represent text
in the program and we can perform many
operations on strings in order to
manipulate it
the syntax of string contains a
collection of characters surrounded by
double quotes for example here string is
the type Str is the name of the string
and coffee is the value that is assigned
to the string
in C plus plus there are two ways to
create a string
first is C style strings in C style
strings collection of characters are
stored in the form of arrays they are
basically arrays of type character
the second way is using string objects
we can create string object to hold a
string
they are implemented in the standard
Library which we must include in the
program using hash include
so here we will do an example of string
and we'll do some push back and pull
back operation on it so first of all
we'll include the header file
Dash include iostream
then using namespace standard
namespace standard okay now we'll start
with int Main
all right first of all we'll write
string
data type then the name of the string s
here s is the name of the string all
right now first of all we will display a
message
to enter a string
so
okay enter a string
now
get line
this is the syntax when you want to take
the input
of a string so get line C in is used to
take the input and S is the name of the
string
so this is how we take the input
and now we will print another message
saying that
you have entered
now here we will print the string s
next line handle okay
now
we'll do some operations like s dot
pushback
this will add an element at the end of
the string
so
let's say we want to add y
yes so we'll write y inside the bracket
s dot pushback and inside the bracket
with single quotes we'll write y
now
will display a message saying
after
using
pushback function
will print the string
that is after using the function
pushback the string would look like this
and
now
we'll use another function s dot pop
back
it will delete the element from the end
so we'll write C out
and we'll display the message
after using PowerBack function
let's write pop back only
and we'll print the
string
okay now after that we'll write return
0.
and I think it's done only the spelling
is wrong over here
okay
yeah now let's try to run this
as you can see the message enter a
string so let's say I have entered
Barcelona
so you have entered Barcelona after
using pushback Barcelona why because we
have used y over here we want to add y
at the end of the string so after using
pushback Barcelona Y and pop back
function after that we have used and we
know that it will delete the element
from the end so here we can see there is
no y pop back function have deleted the
element
so this is our output
next is if file statements
if else are two conditional statements
that are generally used when we want to
run the code based on some conditions
we run a block of code which is inside
if statement only if the condition is
true for example
if the number variable here is equal to
10 then only the block of code will
execute and will print the message you
got it
otherwise it will run the else block and
display the message written inside that
block which is not this one so first of
all we'll create a new file we'll go to
file and click on this new file
now in order to save this one we can
click on control s or we can go over
here and click on this save as
now we can select the location
like
let's keep it over here only
let's name it as
visual dot CPP dot CPP is extension
which is used when we want to do a
program in C plus plus
now I will click on this save button
now let's do a simple program to check
whether the program is running on this
code editor or not
so we'll include the header files
include iostream
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now inside end main will display a
message
welcome to this video
okay now return zero
make sure to save this after making
changes or you can click on Ctrl s or
you can go to file
and click on this save
so once you have saved the program now
you can run it
we can click on this play button it will
run the code
as we can see in the output
welcome to this video we can see
here it is
so it means our program is working it is
running fine now let's do another
example in which we will take the inputs
from the user
so let's make a new file
we'll go to file and click on this new
file
now we'll save as
and we'll write visual
2 dot CPP
all right in this program we'll take the
input from the user
so start with
header files hash include iostree
our spelling is wrong
hash include iostream after that using
namespace standard
now inside int Main
will take the inputs from the user
will display the message
enter the
first number
Now using C in
we'll take the input
we forgot to mention this declare this
N1 variable so write int N1
int and 2.
and int
sum equals 0.
all right here we have taken the input
of N1 the first number now we'll take
the input of another number by
displaying the message
enter the second number
we'll write N2
now we'll
add both of these
and one plus
and 2.
and will display the result
we'll write end line
so that it looks good
all right now we need to save it
we'll go to file and click on this save
now it is saved now we can run this
program
I will click on this run code
now in order to write the first number
over here that is in order to write in
the terminal we have to configure the
visual studio code and to do that
we'll go to file
and will now go to preference and in the
settings we'll click on the settings
and here we will type run in terminal
all right now we can scroll down
and here we can see code Runner running
terminal in my vs Studio it is already
marked but you have to mark this if you
want to write in terminal or enter the
inputs in the terminal
all right once you have marked this you
can
close it and then you can control s that
is save and then you can close the Via
studio and then open it again
once you are done
now
let's try to run this
so now you will be able to write the
inputs
like let's say
the first number is 4
now the second number let's say
nine
on addition it becomes 13 which is the
right answer
so these were some configurations that
you need to do if you want to run a
program of C plus plus in Visual Studio
code
so as we have understood how to download
and configure Visual Studio code for C
plus plus programs so let's move on to
learn how we can download Dev C plus
plus and run C plus plus programs in
that
so let's go to Google
foreign
Dev C plus plus
this is the first link
we'll click on that now this is the
green button saying download will click
on that to download Dev C plus plus
as you can see it is getting downloaded
your download will start shortly
so now we'll click on download now
it is getting downloaded
it will take a while the size of this
file is 48.1 MB
so as you can see the downloading is
almost done
so the downloading is complete now we'll
click on open folder
here it is Dev C plus plus setup now
we'll click on this setup
we click on yes
the setup is loading
so now here we will select the preferred
language it is English we'll click on OK
now we'll click on this is the license
agreement we'll click on I agree
now
we'll click on next we don't need to
change this I think the space required
is 346.8 MB
and we'll click on next
now if you want to change the
destination folder you can but I don't
want to change it so I'll click on
install
now it is getting installed
it will take a while
it's done and now we'll click on finish
and it is marked so when we click on
finish it will launch the dev C plus
plus
so here we have to select the language
it is English so we'll click on next
here again we'll click on next and now
we'll click on OK
so this is our code editor that is Dev C
plus plus
so let's write a code
first of all let's create a file
we'll go to file and go to new and we'll
click on source file
all right now we need to save this one
and in order to save this we'll click on
file then we'll go to save as
and now we'll select the destination
and name it as
dev.cpp
all right now let's start
with the header file
hash include I have stream
we'll do a simple program over here
using namespace
STD
because we want to check that whether
the program is running in this editor or
not
namespace STD
now we'll write int Main
inside into main will display a message
welcome
to
Dev C plus plus
all right after that we'll write return
now let's try to run this and in order
to run this program we'll go to execute
and now we'll click on compile and run
here this is the pop-up welcome to Dev C
plus plus as we can see this is the
output now press any key to continue it
will close this window
so our output is correct welcome to Dev
C plus plus so this is how you can run a
program in Dev C plus plus
and
our program was also working fine in the
visual studio code so this is how you
can download both of these code editors
to run the C plus programs today we'll
be discussing about loops in C plus plus
so let's begin and see what's in it for
you
so we are going to be learning today
about while Loops what is a loop then
different types of Loops like for Loop
while loop do while loop then there is
nested Loop after that there are control
flow statements like break and continue
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting Tech videos
so let's start with the first topic that
is while loops
in order to perform a particular task or
operation many number of times we need
loops these are used when we want to
execute a block of statement repeatedly
rather than just writing those
statements again and again
for example imagine you want to display
your name on the screen 50 times now to
do that there are two methods method one
is writing your name 50 times by doing
the hard code
and Method two is writing your name once
with the loop condition and your name
will be automatically displayed 50 times
now it is pretty obvious that you would
prefer the second approach because you
don't have to put effort in writing your
name 50 times plus it is easy to write
code in few lines
so method 2 is the functionality of loop
it reduces time in writing the code plus
it increases the simplicity
now let's understand what is a loop
Loops in computer programming is a
series of tasks that are used to run
some particular code repeatedly until a
specific condition is met
Loops tells the computer when to start
the condition and when to stop it
now this is a basic flow of a loop after
the initialization the condition is
checked if it's true then the blog of
statement will get executed as long as
the condition is true and if the
condition is false the loop will
terminate
depending on the program different types
of Loops are used in different times
so let's first see different types of
loops
first is for Loop then while loop then
there is do while loop after that there
is nested Loop these are four types of
Loops in C plus plus so let's discuss
these loops
first is for Loop it is a repetition
control structure that is used to
iterate a piece of code based on the
condition is true or false if the
condition is true the statement inside
the loop body is executed and once if it
transforms the execution of statement
will get terminated and after every
execution of for Loop the incremental
decrement paths will update the loop
counter
now let's move on to the while loop
in this Loop the condition is evaluated
first if it's true then the set of
instructions inside the loop body will
execute then this will happen repeatedly
until the condition becomes false and
when it becomes false the loop will end
now the main difference is we use for
Loops when we know the number of times
the body of the loop needs to run
whereas we use while Loops when we don't
know the accrual number of times the
body of loop needs to run
now moving to the next Loop that is do
by Loop
this Loop is quite similar to the while
loop in this the loop will execute the
set of instructions once before checking
if the condition is true after that it
will repeat the loop as long as the
condition is true
that means in do while blue body will
execute at least once irrespective of
the test condition
now coming to the nested Loop
when one Loop is defined inside the body
of another loop then it is known as
nested Loop in C plus plus there are at
least 256 levels of nesting and the flow
of execution for nested Lopez First it
includes initialization of variable
followed by condition 1 if it gets
satisfied then it will search for the
second condition if that also gets
satisfied then it will get increment and
when the condition gets satisfied it
will search for the new set of
statements and follows the same flow of
execution
in C plus plus break statements are used
to terminate the execution of the loop
and by terminating the execution of loop
we means finishing or stopping the
execution like if we want to block or
terminate a loop at some point all we
need to do is to use the break statement
with a condition on which we want the
loop to stop and it will terminate the
Loop's flow or iterations so break
statements are mainly used for two cases
one is it can be used inside the loop
and second is it is mostly used in
switch statements and this is the loops
flow diagram in which first there is a
loop body then if the condition is true
then there is a break statement which
will terminate the loop and if the
condition is not true then the loop will
continue to iterate
as you can see in this example the loop
is iterating from 0 to 10 inside the
loop there is a condition and then the
break statement which will make sure
that the loop will terminate when I
becomes equal to 4. after the break
statement the control will jump out of
the loop body and that's how the break
statement Works its output would be 0 1
2 3. it will not exceed 4 because of the
break statement now coming to continue
statement the continue statement is a
bit similar to the break statement as it
is also used for termination but the
difference is that it is used to
terminate the current iteration and not
the complete Loop for example if a loop
is iterating from 0 to 6 and inside the
loop there is a continue statement on 4.
then all the elements will be printed
except for because continue statement
skips that particular iteration and
continues with the next one
and in break statement the complete Loop
flow terminates
so when the continue statement is used
then within the loop the control skips
or terminates that particular iteration
and continues with the next iteration
as you can see in this example first
Loop body
then there is a condition if that is
true then the continue statement will
terminate and continues it with the next
iteration and if that is false then
control will go to the remaining part of
the as always
now in this example we are using
continue statement here the loop is
iterating from 0 to 10
inside the loop there is a condition and
then the continue statement which will
make sure that if the value of I becomes
4 then terminate that iteration and
moves to the next iteration
after that elements are getting printed
with the help of C out function
now its output would be 1 2 3 5 6 7 8 9.
it will not display 4 because of
continuous statements as we know that
the continuous statement skip that
particular iteration so when we use I
equals 2 equals to 4 then it skips that
particular iteration
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
all right so as we have covered the
theoretical part so now let's do some
examples on break and continue
statements in our code editor that is vs
code
now we'll make a new file
and we'll name that file as
loops.cpp
okay
oops1.cpp
foreign
in which we have to print the digits
from 0 to 10 using for loops it will be
a basic program just to understand it
write the header file
hash upload I'll stream
now I will write using namespace
standard
now here is the ink name
now we will write the for loop with a
four keyboard
inside the for Loop
will initialize I with 0
now we'll put a condition I less than
equal to 10.
which means
the loop will keep on executing until I
is less than 10.
now
we'll put increment I plus plus
now inside the loop brackets all we have
to do is to print I
so that all the digits get printed
so now let me tell you here what we are
doing is
we are just making the loop to run from
0 to 10. as we can see that I have made
i 0
to I less than equal to 10 that means
Loop will move from i 0 to 10.
now let's try to run it
here we can see
all the digits zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
here is our answer and
let me tell you one thing more to put
return zero
after the loop it's a good practice
now I'll again run it
the output will be the same but it's a
good practice to write return 0 in the
end
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten so instead of writing the
hard code we can just use the for Loop
in this case
it's an basic example of for Loop but
you can try some more examples in order
to understand it better
now let's do one example of while loop
we'll be doing a basic example of while
loop in which all we have to do is to
print happy New Year 11 times
let's start first of all let's name this
file
loops2.cpp
now let's start with the header file
that is Hash include iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now is the main
now first of all we'll declare n equals
0 we'll take a variable n and initialize
it with 0.
now we'll put the while condition with
the while keyword writing while
n
not equal to 11.
here what it means is
the loop will keep on executing until n
becomes equal to 11.
now here all we have to do is to print
happy New Year so that it will get
printed along with the Loop 11 times
now we'll write n Plus
we have written n plus plus so that the
loop will keep on incrementing every
single time
after that now we'll write return 0
outside the loop
now we'll try to run this
so here's our output happy New Year 11
times so this is how it's done
this is again a basic example of while
loop but to understand it better one
must practice some more examples on it
now let's do one example of do while
loop also
foreign
let's make a new file
first of all let's name that file
loops3.cpp
I think the name is already taken
then we'll write loops4.cpp
okay now so we'll write the header file
first of all
we'll write hash include live stream
after that using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
we have to print the sum of all the
digits from 0 to 9.
so let's start
we'll write int Main
so now let's first of all declare a
counting variable sum and initialize it
with 0.
now we will initialize another variable
I
with 0.
now the syntax will do while loop is
do keyword
and now we will add some code inside the
body
will write sum equals sum plus I
here what we are doing is we are simply
adding some variable and I variable and
storing it to some variable itself
we are doing this because we want to
find the sum that is why we have to
store it in a single variable
now we will need to increment I or else
Loop is going to run forever
now we will write file
I less than 10 we have written I less
than 10 because we want to find the sum
from 0 to 9.
and make sure to put a semicolon in the
end in case of 2 while loop
now we will print
some
in this while loop
we'll write sum is
some variable
now this Loop will keep on executing
till I is less than 10.
now in the do while loop sum is
calculated by repeated addition and
increment
in each repetition it is checked whether
the number I is smaller or equal to the
inputted number
if it is smaller then the loop continues
but exits the loop if it isn't
after the control exits from the loop
sum is printed
now let's try to run this code
here it is
sum is 45.
which is the right answer this is our
output
so this is how it is done in do while
loop
so now let's do one example of our last
Loop that is nested Loop
first of all we'll name the file
loops pipe.cpp
now we'll start with the header files
Now using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print a star pattern of half pyramid
form using nested Loop
so let's try
we'll write into Main
now let's initialize two variables that
is I
and J
now let's say we want to make a half
pyramid of 10 rows then it means we need
to run a loop which runs for 10 times
so let's write
or
initialize it to zero
I less than
10.
I plus plus
now here we have written I less than 10.
instead of this we'll write I less than
equal to 10 because we want the 10th row
to be printed also
now we will print slash n
in order to insert a new line
now we'll write another for Loop
which will decide number of stars in a
particular row
so we'll write J equal to 1 because this
for Loop is for the column section
then J less than equal to I
which is a row
then J plus plus
now we'll print star
now one more thing instead of 0 we'll
write I equals to 1 because we want to
print stars from 1 to 10.
so now let's discuss it's working
initially we have I equals to 1 that is
the outer loop value
now for this value a complete run of jth
loop is happening that is J equal to 1
validated by J less than equal to I
now this condition is used because the
pattern which we are going to build is
having increment of Star as the number
of rows increments
so for I equals to 1 J equals to 1 is
executed then J plus plus is done which
increments the value of J to 2.
now J equals to 2 failed to execute as 2
is less than equal to 1 is false
therefore only one star is printed
[Music]
again we go to ith Loop now for I equal
to 2 we'll check every value of J which
can be executed that is 1 and 2. since
only two values can be true therefore 2
Star are printed
similarly we check for I equal to 3 4 5
and so on till 9. as we have the
condition I is less than 10.
so now we'll try to run this
and check whether the pattern is
printing or not
here it is
half pyramid form using stars with the
help of nested loops
so this is our star pattern
we can make some more different types of
patterns using nested loops
but we have done only one example in
order to understand the concept
so now let's move to our control flow
statements
and let's do some examples of them
okay now
make a new file
let's name this file as
Ctrl 1.
CPP
now we'll write the header file and the
namespace standard as we have done
previously
so let's do it
Dash include
live stream
using namespace STD
now here
we will write a program in which we have
to print the numbers from 100 to 200
like 110 hundred and twenty hundred and
thirty with a gap of 10.
but after 150 we will terminate the
ongoing Loop now how can it be done with
the help of break statement so let's
start
first of all we'll write intimate
now we'll take a variable num
and initialize it with hundred
now we'll write a while condition
and we'll write num is less than equal
to 200 because we want the loop to run
from 100 to 200.
num less than equal to 200
now we'll simply display those numbers
now we'll write any condition that if
num equals 150
then we'll terminate the loop and for
that we have to write the break
statement inside the if statement
so let's write
if num equals equals 150
then we have to break the loop
write the break statement
now after that we'll implement this
by 10.
we are incrementing this by 10 because
we want the numbers to be printed like
100 110 120 like this that is why we are
incrementing it with 10 and not with 1.
now we'll write out of the loop
just to be informed that we are finally
out of the loop
return zero
now we'll try to run this
here we can see here here we can see 100
110 120 up 250 after that we are out of
the loop
this means
the code works fine
so this is the example of a break
statement now after this we'll do
another example of continue
so let's start
let's make a new file
and name it
ctrl2.cpv
now we'll write the header files
[Music]
using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print the numbers from 100 to 90.
only excluding 96 from them
now how do we do it with the help of
continue statement
so let's start
first of all we'll write into Main
now we'll declare a variable
num and initialize it with 100.
now we'll write a while condition
while loop in which we write the
condition num greater than equal to 90
because we want the loop to run till it
is equal to 90 that is why we have wrote
greater than equal to 90. basically we
want the loop to run from 100 till it
becomes equal to 90.
now inside the loop we'll write the if
condition in order to skip 96. so we'll
write
if
num equals 96 num
quilts equals 96.
now we'll use a decrement operator
because our starting point is 100 and
ending point is 90 that is why we have
to use the decrement operator
now continue statement
after that write
value is
and we'll write the variable num
now we'll write num minus minus
here we are writing minus minus because
we want it to get decrement after
printing also that is why we have
written num minus minus after printing
num
now let's try to run this also hope it
works
okay I think there are some errors
so
some brackets were missing
thank you
and we'll write return 0.
now we'll try to run it
here it is
as we can see
199.98 97
but 96 is missing
so this is all we have to do in this
program
and this is the basic example of
continue statement
in order to understand these examples
better you must try more examples on
each of these loops and control flow
statements so that it will be easier for
you all today we'll be discussing about
C plus functions so let's go ahead and
look what's in it for us
first we'll discuss what is a function
then we'll understand why we use
functions then types of functions like
built-in function and user defined
function then function declaration after
that function calling then function call
methods and at last we have recursion
also don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to the first topic that is
what is a function
functions are blocks of code that are
designed to perform a specific task
it basically divides the complex problem
into smaller portions and make the
program easy to understand and reusable
and by reusable it means we can Define
the code once and we can use it many
times
we can also pass data into the functions
in the form of parameters
and this is the syntax
first is return type of the function
then we will write function name then
inside the bracket these are the
parameters
now let's discuss why we use functions
functions make the program less
complicated because once function is
defined in the program then it can be
used over and over again which reduces
the complexity of code
and it helps in avoiding the duplicity
of code and it reduces the amount of
code due to this we can easily debug and
maintain the code
now coming to the types of functions
there are two types of functions in C
plus plus that is built-in functions and
user defined function
now let's discuss these functions
first is built-in function
these are also known as predefined
functions or Library functions we don't
need to Define these functions because
these are already present in C plus
libraries and the implementation of
these functions are also available in
library file
and to use these functions we don't have
to write them separately we simply call
them now coming to the user defined
functions
C plus plus allows us to Define our own
functions these functions are created by
programmers according to their
requirement
this allows a way to wrap a set of
statements to perform a specific task
and that group of statement is given a
name so that it can be invoked later
from any part of the program
following is the example of user defined
function here Club is a user defined
function with the return type wired and
it is being called from the main
function now let's learn about function
declaration
function declaration basically acts as
an identification for the function
it informs the compiler about the
existence of function function's name
the number of parameters in the function
and its return type
these things acts as an identifier for a
function
and this is the Syntax for a function
declaration
first we will write the return type then
we will write the name of the function
after that inside the bracket we will
write the number of parameters
for example in this chess function int
is the return type chess is the name of
the function
and inside the brackets these are the
number of parameters
although we can write the names of
parameters but names of parameters are
not important in the function
declaration only their type is required
now let's learn about function calling
in order to use a function we'll have to
invoke or call a function when a program
calls a function the control of the
program is transferred to the called
function and when the code function
completes its task then the control is
returned back to the main program
so the functions are called by writing
the name of function and after that
writing the required parameters inside
the brackets
and this is the syntax
first we will write the function name
and after that we will write the
arguments which you want to pass
for example sum is the function name and
a and b are the arguments so first is
call by value
call by value is a method in which
copies of variables are passed to the
functions and as the copies of variables
or arguments are being passed so that is
why the changes that are done inside the
function does not affect the arguments
and this is the syntax inside int main
we can see that we are calling a
function and passing the values here
well 1 and Val 2 are the actual
parameters these are those which are
passed to the functions
and inside the brackets of call function
we can see N1 and N2
these are formal parameters format
parameters are those which are received
by the function
so here we can say values of actual
parameters that is well 1 and Val 2 will
be copied to the formal parameters that
is N1 and N2
now let's have a look at an example in
which we are swapping two numbers
as we can see inside int main we have
assigned 120 to X and 152i
after that we have called a function
named swap it
and inside the brackets we are passing
the values of X and Y
and these values are getting received by
called function
and inside that function there is a
logic to swap the code with the help of
temporary variable temp
and these values of X and Y are then
discrete inside int Main
but its output is same
access still 120 and Y is still 150
there is no change after swapping it
also
so this shows that actual value of the
variable is not getting modified
this shows that changes done to the
parameters inside the function does not
affect the arguments
now let's learn about call by reference
in this method instead of passing the
arguments the address of the argument is
passed to the formal arguments of the
function
and the address is used to access the
actual argument referring to the same
location so any changes that are made
gets reflected to the actual parameter
this is the syntax of call by reference
in which we have assigned 200 to the
variable num and then the address of
this variable is passed to the function
and 20 is assigned to it
now on displaying the output the value
would be 20 and not 200 because the
value is assigned to the memory location
that is why change is getting reflected
now let's have a look at an example of
swap
this is the same example as that of the
call by value but instead of passing the
copies of variable we are passing the
address of the variable and inside the
function values are getting swapped with
the help of temp variable and then it is
getting displayed in the main function
in this case we can see in the output
the values of variables are actually
swapped m is now 300 and N is now 250.
now let's do some examples of call by
value and call by reference in our code
editor that is vs code
now we will do an example of call by
value in which we will try to change the
salary with the help of a function
so let's start first of all let's make a
new file
and name it
call one dot CPP
now we will include the header files
hash include
i o stream
now we will add namespace standard
now first of all we'll write int Main
and we will declare a variable cell
and assign a value 27
000 let's say
salary to this cell variable
now we will call a function
let's name that function as salary
underscore change
and now inside the brackets we'll write
cell
as we know that in call by value
we pass the copies of the variable
so
now we'll display
that variable
we'll write
value
inside Main
and now we will write the variable name
cell
and handle
now
return zero
now let's make the function salary
change
we'll write
void
salary underscore
change
let's avoid
now here we will write hint the data
type and the variable
s that is the formal parameter cell here
is the actual parameter and S is the
formal parameter
now
we will assign as a new value
let's say 30 000.
here we have assigned as 30 000 earlier
the value of cell was 27 000 and then we
passed the copy of the variable cell
to the function salary change and there
we assigned 30 000 to it
so let's print over here
value
foreign
function
[Music]
cell
here we have to write s
because the variable name is s
okay now let's try to run this
foreign
here we can see value inside function is
30 000. and value inside main is 27 000.
here we can see the value of the
variable that is passed gets changed but
the original value inside the main
function doesn't changes so we can say
changes are not reflected to the
original value which happens in call by
Value method
so now let's do one example of call by
reference
let's make a new file
called to
dot CPP
let's include the header files
hash include
i o stream
chocolate
now we'll write using namespace standard
now we'll start with int Main
here we will declare a variable cell and
assigned 27 000 to it
as we have done previously now we'll
call a function named increment
and inside the bracket we will pass
the address of cell
as we know that in case of call by
reference we pass the address
so after that we'll just write the
message saying
salary
inside
Main
and
write the variable cell
then handle
after that we'll write return 0.
now our job is to write the
function
we'll write void
increment
and here
we write Ampersand sign s
because here we are passing the address
not any copy of the value or the
variable here we are passing the address
of the variable
so that is why we have used Ampersand
sign now
we will simply write the logic to
increment so we'll write s equals S Plus
5000 let's say we want the salary to
increment by 5000.
then we will display
the variable s so first of all we'll
write the message
salary
inside
function
foreign
the name of the variable after that
handle
now let's try doing this
here we can see that the salary inside
the function is 32 000 and salary
outside
the function that is inside the main
function is 32 000 as well
here we can see that the changes are
reflected to the original values as well
in the main function and we know that in
case of call by reference any change
inside the function is reflected outside
the function because we are passing the
address of the variable
so this is our output 32 032 000 so
these were some basic examples of call
by value and call by reference now here
we will do a program in which we have to
do the sum of two integers with the help
of function
so let's first of all make a new file
function dot CPP
okay so let's start first of all we'll
declare the header files that is Hash
include as stream
now the namespace standard
now we will write int Main
now inside end main we will declare a
variable named s
here we have declared this variable
because we want to store the sum of
those two integers in this variable
so
we'll call the function let's say let's
name the function as sum
and let's
assume the variables to be 5 and 5.
here sum is the name of the function and
5 comma 5 are the arguments now we'll
make the function sum
here end is the return type
sum is the name
and
a comma ENT B
are the parameters
so in this function we'll write the code
to do the sum of these two integers and
for that we have to store the sum in a
variable
for that we will now declare a variable
C
now we will write C equals a plus b
here we are storing the sum of a plus b
into the variable C
now as we know that the return type is
end so we have to return the variable
instead of printing it
will write
return
C
now in the main function
we'll print that variable
we will print the variable as because
after the function completes its task of
addition the output will come back to
the calling function which is getting
stored in the variable s
so
we'll write
the result is
now we will write the variable s
let's see
hope it runs
the result is 10.
five plus five on addition will get 10.
let's write three
and again
try to run this
the result is 8.
5 plus 3 equals to eight so this is the
right answer
now we will do another example of C plus
plus function
in which we have to find the larger
number of Greater number among two
elements
so let's do that
let's create a new file
function1.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include iostream
Now using namespace standard
now first of all we'll write the in
plane
now the variable N1
now we will declare another variable N2
these are the two variables among which
we have to find the greater number
so
we'll display a message saying that
enter
the first number
now we'll take the input
N1
now we'll do the same for the other one
will write
foreign
we'll input the second number
now
we have to make a call to the function
named let's say maxi
and we will pass these arguments N1
comma into
now let's make this function maxi
the return type is void
maxi
is the name
we'll write the variables N1
um
and two
now we'll write the if condition because
we have to find the greater number among
both these elements so we'll write the
if condition if N1 is greater than N2
then it must print the N1
will also display a message saying that
the larger number is
foreign
if N1 is greater than N2 then we'll
display the N1
and
if N2 is greater
then we'll display the N2
we'll write the variable N2
foreign
so let's see if that runs or not
I think we have to write the first
number here we can see enter the first
number
enter the first number so we will write
let's say
and the second number would be
the larger number is 78. so
among both the numbers as we know that
70s is greater than 56 so this is how we
can show it with the help of functions
so these were some basic samples of C
plus plus functions and in today's
session we will learn about C plus plus
recursion now let's have a look at what
we'll be covering today
first of all we'll discuss what is
recursion then we'll understand the
working of recursion that is how it
actually works after that we will learn
about types of recursion and at last we
will go through the advantages and
disadvantages of recursion so what is
recursion recursion can be defined as a
process in which a function calls itself
again and again until a certain
condition is met recursion basically
brings about several number of iterative
calls to the same function however it is
important to have a base case to end the
recursion
for example imagine you are calling your
friend again and again for an urgent
piece of work until he picks up the call
now here calling your friend again and
again or one after the other is a
recursive function and when he picks up
your call is the termination condition
and this is the basic syntax where the
function name is recursion and it is
being called from the main function and
inside the recursion function it is
calling itself now let's understand it's
working
in a recursive function there are two
parts that is the recursive case and the
base case in the recursive case the
function is being called by itself again
and again and the base case is when the
function finally stop calling itself
so when the recursive function is called
from the main function then the call
function will execute and it keeps on
repeating as it is being called by
itself from within the function again
and again until it meets the base case
that will terminate its calling
for example factorial of 5 in this
problem we can see a pattern n into
factorial of n minus 1. to be clear n is
5. so n minus 1 is 4. and it is going on
till n becomes 0.
here factorial is the recursive function
and N minus 1 is the argument that is
getting passed for every n into the
recursive function in this case if n
becomes 0 or 1
it is the base case and N into factorial
n minus 1 is the recursive condition
now let's understand the types of
recursion
first is direct recursion as the name
suggests in this type of recursion
function calls itself directly for
example void recursion here recursion is
the name of the function and is being
called by itself from within the
function directly although there is no
base case in this example but it shows
the idea of direct recursion
now coming to indirect recursion when a
function calls itself indirectly that is
if a function calls some other function
to make a recursive call then it is
known as indirect function
for example here recursion function is
calling some other function sub
and sub function is calling the
recursion function here both the
functions are calling other functions to
make a recursive call this is called
indirect recursion now coming to
advantages and disadvantages of
recursion the advantages are in
recursion we only need to define the
base case and the recursive case
so therefore it provides a Simple and
Clean way to write a code
second is recursion is more preferred in
problems like tree traversals Tower of
annoy graphs because these are
inherently recursive problems now
disadvantages disadvantages are the
recursive program generally acquires
more space than the iterative program
this is because after every call to the
function each function call will keep on
adding to the stack until the base case
is reached
second is it requires more amount of
time because of function calls now let's
do some examples of recursion on our
code editor that is vs code now here we
will do a program in which we will find
the sum of natural number up to a number
which we will enter and we will do this
example using recursion
so let's start
first of all we'll name this
recursion
dot CPP
okay now we will start with writing
header file that is Hash include
iostream
now we'll add namespace standard
using name space
STD
now first of all we'll write int Main
now we will declare a variable let's say
num
so basically we want to enter a number
so for that first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter a number
now we'll take the input
input as num
absolutely
so now here we will make a call to the
function and in that function we will
pass the variable num which we have
taken the input of and we will print
this with a message
so let's say
we'll print it like C out
and the message would be
sum is
and this is the function name sum
and this is the variable which we are
passing
to that let's write return 0.
now let's make this function some
will write int the return type
sum the name of the function
and
the variable num
foreign
now first of all we have to make a base
case
so we will write the base case as
we'll make if
num
is not equal to zero
then
here we will write the recursive case
return
num Plus
some
num minus 1.
so here we are adding the numbers with
its previous number and because of
recursive condition it will keep on
calling the same function some function
again and again till the base case that
is num becomes equal to 0 is achieved
and once it is achieved the calling
would be stopped
num not equal to 0 here means that if
num is not equal to 0 then only this
statement num plus sum num minus 1
will execute
Okay so
now after this
will
try to run this
enter the number let's say
five
sum is 15 here we can see
sum is 15.
okay let's recheck 5 plus 4 equals to 9
9 plus 3 equals to 12 12 plus 2 equals 2
14 14 plus 1 equals to 15 so our answer
is correct
so this is how we can find the sum up to
any numbers which we want to find the
sum of and
now let's do another example
so let's name this as
recursion
2 dot CBP
now here we will do a program of
factorial we will enter a number and we
have to find the factorial of that
number
so let's start
first of all we'll write hash include
iostream that is the header file
Now using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
okay now we will declare a variable
number
and we want to take the input from the
user so we'll
display a message saying
enter the number
now we will take the input
we'll write number
now we will call a function and we will
send the pass the argument number as we
have done in the previous question
so let's do it
first of all we will display that
saying
the factorial
of the number
you have entered
is
now we will make a call to the function
let's say the name of the function is
fact
and
will pass the argument number
as we have done previously
now we'll write return 0.
now let's make this function
we will write the in return type int
now fat
after that now we will write the
argument
print number
now we will write if condition
and we'll write
number
less than one
and we will return
one
so here we have wrote this condition
because as we know that the factorial of
0 is 1 and if a number is less than 1
that it means it is 0 and if it is 0
then our program should return 1.
and
you will write now else condition
else
if it is not 0 that means
we will write the recursive condition
that is
number
into
fact
number minus 1.
now this is the condition that is
responsible for finding the factorial of
a number for example if we input 5 then
here we can see the condition would
become 5 into fact 5 minus 1 that is 4.
and this 4 will be passed as argument to
this fact function and then the
condition would become 4 into fact 4
minus 1 that is 3 and it is also passed
to the function and similarly it will go
on until it becomes less than 1.
now let's try to run this
enter the number
let's say six
the factorial of number you have entered
is 720 and we know that the factorial of
6 is 720 so this is the right answer
and let me tell you this is uh this is
the base case and this is the recursive
case in this program
now after that let's do one last example
of recursion
okay so now let's make new file
and name this file
now first of all we'll add the header
files
are your stream
now namespace standard using name
space standard
so here we will do the program of
Fibonacci series and we know that
Fibonacci series is basically each num
in Fibonacci series each number is
basically the sum of its two previous
numbers
so let's start so first of all we'll
make int Main
now
we'll declare a variable num
now we want to take the input from the
user so first of all we'll display a
message saying that
enter the number
now we'll take the input
we'll write num
now
we will make a for Loop and iterate that
loop from i 0 to num
so we'll write for keyword
int I equal to 0
I less than num
I plus plus
now inside the loop we will write C out
to display and we will call fibo
function and we will pass I as an
argument because we want to print the
series
so we will write C out
fibo
and we'll pass I
as an argument and
just for the space
now we'll write return
0.
in fibo function we have passed is an
argument because we want to print the
series
so first 0 will be passed then 1 will be
passed after then 2 will be passed and
so on
so now we will make the function fibo
hint is the return type fibo is the name
now the argument num
now in this fibo function we will put if
condition for checking if the num is
equal to 0 or 1. if yes we will return
the value of num else we will
recursively call fibo using n minus 1
and N minus 2 because Fibonacci series
is basically the sum of previous two
numbers
so first of all we'll write
if
num
is less than equal to 1.
then
return
num
else
return
fibo
num minus 1
Plus
fibo
brackets num minus 2.
because we know
Fibonacci series is basically the sum of
previous two numbers
now if the
num is 0 or 1 then it will go to the if
statement and if it is greater than 0
and 1 then it will go to this recursive
statement
so for example if n equals to 2 then we
will call recursively 2 minus 1 and 2
minus 2 that is 1 and 0 respectively
since 2 minus 1 will give 1 and 2 minus
2 will give 0 these will be evaluated in
if statement as they are less than equal
to 1 so it will give 0 plus 1 that is
equal to 1.
now let's try to run this code
enter the number
let's say six
zero one one two three five which is the
right answer
the Fibonacci sequence for six is zero
one one two three five
so this is how we can do Fibonacci
series or Fibonacci Sequence with the
help of recursion
and I suggest you to do some more
examples on recursion to understand it
better in this session we will learn
about friend functions in C plus plus so
let's go ahead and have a look at what
we'll be covering today in this session
we will cover topics like why do we need
a friend function what is a friend
function in C plus plus then the
Declaration of friend function and after
that we will learn what is a friend
class then we will understand features
of friend function and its advantages
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update so
first is why do we need a friend
function friend functions are used when
we want to access the private or
protected members of the class but
without the help of the objects it helps
us in avoiding the case where the
functions must be a member of both the
classes in order to access them or in
other words a function doesn't have to
be a member of both the classes in order
to access the class data a friend
function is also used to perform
operator overloading like functions
operators can also be overloaded and
because of the friend function it is
possible now let's understand what is a
friend function a friend function is not
a member function of the class and it is
defined outside the class
and we know outside members cannot
access the class data but the friend
function can access those private public
and protected class data because the
friend function is friendly with the
class now let's move to Declaration of
friend function the Declaration of Rand
function must be done inside the class
the friend function is declared using
the front keyword then the return type
then the name of the function that is
made a friend of the class its
definition is done outside the class and
we don't use the front keyword while
defining it but while declaring it
inside the class we use the front
keyword now coming to the next topic
that is what is a friend class exactly
like a friend function a class can also
be a friend of another class A Friend
class is that class that can access the
data members and member functions of a
class to which it is a friend we need to
pass the objects of the class us to a
member function of the friend class if
we want to access those private and
protected members also if the classes
are declared friends then all the member
functions of the class will be a friend
function to the friend class now let's
have a look at the syntax here we have
done the forward Declaration of class
table this will allow the access of the
objects of the class table in the class
club inside the class club we have
declared friend class table that means
the class table is a friend of class
club and it can access members of that
class after that we have defined the
class table without the front keyword as
we can see now coming to features of
friend function so here are some
features of friend functions so let's
start with the first one that is a
friend function can be easily invoked
just like a normal function it doesn't
require any object or so to invoke
next is the scope of a friend function
is not limited it can be a member of
another class as well third is a friend
function can be declared in any part
that is private protected or public
parts of the class fourth is the object
of the class can be used as an argument
for the function and the last is a
friend function can access the members
by using the object name and Dot
operator along with the member's name
now coming to advantages of friend
function the First Advantage is with the
help of Rand function we are able to
access the non-public members of the
class that is the private members the
second Advantage is fan function helps
in operator overloading and the third
Advantage is because of the friend
function we are able to share the
private information by a known member
function as friend function is not a
member function the last Advantage is
fan function allows us to generate more
more efficient code so these were some
advantages of friend function so now
let's go ahead and do some examples on
friend functions to understand it in a
better way so let's open our Visual
Studio code and do some examples so
first of all let's make a new file let's
name it friend1 dot CPP
all right so now here we'll do a simple
program of Rand function so let's start
with including the header file hash
include Diamond stream now we will write
using namespace standard
all right
and inside the main function first of
all we will create an object of a class
let's say the name of the class is
salary and the name of the object is s
all right after that we will
simply write return 0 and we will do the
rest of this after creating the class so
we need to First create the class now
we'll write class
salary which is the name of the class
and inside this class first of all we'll
write private access modifier and here
we will write or declare
a variable named cell after that now we
will write or declare the friend
function so we know how to declare a
friend function we'll write friend
keyword
then the return type that is int and
then the name of the
function let's say increment and then
the objects as we know we have to pass
the name of the class with the object
because we want to access the private
member of the class so salary s which is
the object
and after the class we'll write the
semicolon now we have to create or
Define this increment friend function
we'll write
int increment here we haven't used the
front keyword because this is the
definition now inside the arguments
we'll pass the
the object
all right now inside the main function
we will call this friend function so
first of all we will display a message
saying that
increment
is
that the increment in the salary is
and then we will call this function
and we will pass this object
all right now inside this increment
function which is a print function we
will use object as dot operator and then
the name of the variable which is
private
now all we need to do is to increment
this salary variable we'll write s dot
cell plus 7000 which is the increment
and then we will return
s dot cell all right now as we can see
this increment function which is not a
member function of this class is
accessing this private variable of
salary class and is incrementing 7000 to
the salary so now let's save it first
and let's try to run this
there is some error let's have a look at
that
all right yeah there is some spelling
mistake increment now let's save it
and run it so as we can see increment is
7000 so this is the correct output
so this was a simple example of friend
function let's do another example so
here we will do an example of friend
class and we know friend class is a
class that can access the data members
and member functions of a class to which
it is a friend
so let's start first of all we'll
include the header files
hash include iostream
and then the namespace standard
and we forgot to name this file so let's
do it let's name it friend2.cpp
all right now let's proceed
int main inside the main function first
of all we will create an object of a
class let's say the class name is num2
and its object is
obj2 object two now for now let's say
we'll write only return 0 we'll do this
part later onwards now let's create the
class all right so the class name would
be num2 num1 actually but we know in
front class we have to do the forward
declaration so we will write
class num 2 so this is a forward
Declaration of class num2 now
inside class num1 first of all we'll
declare a variable in private
so let's say the name of the variable is
int N1 enters the data type and one is
the name of the variable
now we have to do the Declaration of
friend class so we'll write front
keyword after that
class
num2 which is the name of the class
all right after this let's create this
first of all we have to put the
semicolon all right now let's write this
class num2
so this is our friend class num2 we
haven't used front keyword over here as
we can see
all right in this class we'll use the
private access specifier and
we'll create another variable N2 and
then we will write the public access
specifier and we will create a
Constructor of num2 as this is the name
of the class and this is object we have
created so now we will create the
Constructor of this class
num2 and now in this Constructor we will
initialize N2 with 65 or whatsoever
number we want because in the end we
have to find the average of two
variables so this is the second variable
N2 and we have assigned the value 65 so
now let's make the function of average
because we want to find the average of
both the numbers
so enter the data type AVG is the name
of the function let's say and inside
this function we will make an object of
num1 class and object name is obj1 now
as we have created the object
by mistake we have wrote I obj1 so as we
have created the object of num1 class
with its Constructor would be invoke
which we will create now but first of
all here we will write return
the average so we'll write obj1 Dot N1
plus N2
divided by
so as we know that obj1 is the object of
num1 class so that is why we have used
obj1 dot operator N1 that is the name of
the variable plus N2 divided by 2 from
here we can find the average and before
that we have to create the Constructor
of this class so
now all we need to do is write Public
Access modifier
now num1 and inside this num1 we will
assign the value to N1 variable which is
let's say 11. all right so now in the
main function we have to call this
function avj that is the average
function and
we forgot to put semicolon over here all
right now we'll display a message
average is
and now we will call the function
obj 2 dot AVG which is a function so
here we are calling this function so
let's save this so we have saved this
now let's try to run this one as you can
see the average is 38 so 65 plus 11 6
and 76 divided by 2 which is 38 so this
is the correct output so this is a fine
example of friend class as we know class
num2 is a friend of class num1 so it can
access all the members of class num1 in
class num2 we have created the function
AVG over here this is the function AVG
here we are doing the average of both
the numbers and as class num2 is a
friend of num1 so we can create objects
of num1 in num2 class
and after doing this this is our output
that is average is 38 so this is an
example of friend class now let's do
another example so here we will do an
example of Rand function in which a
friend function is a friend to two
classes and this would be an example in
which we have to do the product of two
numbers so let's start first of all
let's include the header files as we
have done previously
IO stream
namespace standard now let's save it
friend3.cpp and
spelling is wrong
now let's start with the main function
inside the int main first of all we will
create the object of Class A that is a
and Class B object would be small B
and we will use these objects to call
the functions but we will do that part
later onwards first of all we'll simply
write return 0 over here and now we'll
create the classes all right so here we
will create a class but before that we
have to do the forward Declaration of
another class so this is the forward
Declaration of class P and now we can
create the class A
and inside the a class we will declare
the variable X let's say now
we'll use this public scope
and we will create a function within
this class let's say void assign
now inside this function we will pass
the variable I because because we have
to assign the value of this variable I
to the variable X
so
we will assign the value of I to X
like this and before that we have to do
the calling from the main function so we
will do that later first of all we will
create the front function and here we
are declaring this print function
void is the return type product let's
say is the name of this friend function
and a comma B are the arguments
now
let's call this assign function first of
all so all we need to do is we will make
a call from this main function a DOT
assign which is the name of the function
and let's say we have passed the value
45 now here we will create the class B
inside the b class we'll similarly
create another variable y
and now inside the public scope you will
create function of the same name that is
assign now in this assign function we
will pass
I as the argument as we have done in
class A similarly we'll do it over here
we will assign the value of I to this
variable y
once we have done this
then we will declare friend function as
we know that the front function is
friend of both of these classes so we
have to do it inside both of these
classes we have to declare the friend
function and now we will declare the
front function in this class as well
product
all right after the class we will use
the semicolon now
we will create the friend function so
here we are defining the front function
we use void product which is the name of
the function now data type object name
all right now all we need to do is we'll
do this sum a DOT X into B dot Y and now
we'll use semicolon so here a DOT X will
hold the value which have been assigned
that is 45 and now B dot x b dot y will
hold the value which we will call from
here B dot assign
here we are calling and we are assigning
the value let's say 20. you're passing
the value 20 and this 20 value
will be assigned to this Y and 45 into
20 would be the product
so everything is done now all we need to
do is to call the
product function and as we know that the
product function that is the friend
function is the friend of both of the
classes so it can access the private
variables so we'll do that
product
a comma B here we are calling this now
let's save this one and let's try to run
this
there are some errors
let's check them Class A all right so
before go to make some space over here
now let's save it again and let's try to
run this
as we can see the output is 900 so 45
into 20 is equal to 900 which is the
correct answer
and it means the program is working fine
so this is a fine example in which a
function that is this product function
is a friend of both the classes that is
Class B and this class A here we have
done the forward declaration and we have
made the front of Class A and here we
have declared the friend function in
class B and as we can see that this
product function can use or access the
private variables of both the classes
and so this is by using the private
variables we we have done the product of
both of these numbers and its answer is
900 so these were some few examples of
rent functions you can try some more
examples on it it will enhance your
knowledge in Z Plus as it is an
interesting topic welcome to this video
on C plus plus header files and in
today's session we will learn about why
we need header files then what is c plus
header file after that we will learn
about types of header files and how can
we create our own header file and at
last we will have a look at some
examples of header files
header files allows us to assemble all
the predefined functions in one place
and it is helpful because it is easier
to get the Declarations in one place and
then use them whenever we need them
and as all the Declarations are gathered
in one place so it automatically reduces
the complexity and it also decreases the
number of lines of code
there are many functionalities of header
files one of them is it helps in taking
the input from the user and also helps
in displaying the output in a program
now let's learn what actually a c plus
header file is
header files are the set of libraries
that contains predefined functions at a
common place so it basically stores the
Declarations at one common place and
they are being used while writing a
program
these header files usually have a dot h
extension and we use hash include before
writing the header file to inform the
preprocessor that we are including this
header file now let's discuss types of
header files there are two types of
files in C plus first is predefined
header file these files are already
present in C plus compiler we simply
need to import these header files using
hash include which will inform the
compiler about the header file and then
we can write the name of the header file
between the angle brackets
next is user defined header file these
header files are defined or created by
users in C plus plus user can create
their own header file and include it in
the C plus library and it can be used
whenever it is required now let's learn
how to create this header file in order
to create your own header file first of
all we will write the C plus code which
we want to use whenever we want after
that we will save the file with dot h
extension as we can see in Step 1 we
have written the code of two integers
that are getting multiplied
and now we will include this in the
program
to include this in the program we will
use hash include and after that we will
write the name of the header file inside
the angle brackets with the dot h
extension
here hash include will inform the
compiler that a header file is added
and now as we can see in Step 2 after
the Declaration of two integers we are
calling the function product and passing
the arguments X and Y
after running this program we will get
the output as 45. because 9 into 5
equals 45 and we don't need to worry
about writing the logic of it because we
have already included this header file
now let's have a look at some examples
of header files
hash include iostream iostream is the
header file that is used to read and
write the standard input output streams
because of this header file we can take
the input and display the output and in
case of iostream dot h is not used
because after standardization of C plus
plus IO stream became standard header
whose function is now in STD namespace
unlike earlier when functions were
defined in iostream before
standardization
next is f stream fstream are associated
with files it is basically used to read
the information from files and write the
information in it
and next is IU manip IO manip is a
library that is used in the manipulation
of input and output statements
so these were some examples of header
files today we'll be discussing about C
plus plus array so without further Ado
let's get started
so what's in it for you
we will start by understanding why do we
need arrays then what is an array after
that types of array like one dimension
array two Dimension array
multi-dimension array and then memory
representation and lastly we'll go
through error initialization
so first is need of arrays
we use arrays because it allows us to
store similar type of data within
contiguous block of memory
and it allows us to iterate through
those variables conveniently using
indexing
usually an array is used to store
similar kind of data like marks scored
by all the students of a class and
record of attendance of all the
employees in an organization
now moving to what is an array
an array can be defined as a collection
of similar kind of elements these are
always stored in contiguous memory
locations that is one after the other
the total number of elements in an array
is called the length of the array now
this is the way you can visualize the an
array here each block is capable of
storing data values of some type in
sequential Manner and each element can
uniquely identify by its index in the
array
and this is the syntax of array int is
the data type array is the area name and
5 is the size of array
now there are few types of variance C
plus plus
those are
one dimensional two-dimensional array
and multi-dimensional array so let's
first of all discuss 1D array
this is the simplest form of an array in
this array data items are arranged
linearly in one dimension having single
index value to represent data elements
now this is the syntax of 1D array type
is the data type then there is array
name and after that size of array and
this is the example of one dimensional
array
now coming to its memory representation
here we can see 2 7 4 8 1 6 are the
elements inside the memory blocks
and 0 1 2 3 4 5 are the indexes
so by using index we can easily access
the elements and once the array elements
are accessed a number of operations can
be performed
here array of 0 means 2 and array of 1
means 7 and so on
as each element is of type int that is 2
byte that means the array occupies 12
contagious bytes because each block
contain 2 byte and there are total six
blocks
now coming to the two dimensional array
in this array each element is referred
by two indexes that is rows and columns
and they are stored in the form of
matrices the first index shows a row of
the Matrix and the second index shows
the column of The Matrix
now moving to its memory representation
as you can see this is a 2d array with
three rows and three columns and we can
also say that these are basically three
1D array containing three blocks each
combined to form a 2d array in the form
of a matrix with size of 3 cross 3. the
horizontal line step its rows and the
vertical line step its columns and we
know that index starts from 0 so first
elements get stored at array 0 0 that is
0 through and zero column then second
element is stored at array 0 1 that is
zeroth row and column 1 and likewise all
the elements are stored in the array now
coming to the multi-dimensional array
[Music]
these are defined as area of arrays that
means each element of multi-dimension
array is an array itself they can have
any number of dimensions and it stores
the data in tabular form
a two-dimensional array is also
multi-dimensional array
and this is the Syntax for a
here type is the data type of array then
array name is the name of the array and
size 1 size 2 up to so on size n are the
dimension of sizes
after that this is the basic example of
a multi-dimensional array
now coming to the next topic that is air
initialization
so there are two ways to initialize an
array in C plus first is you can
initialize an array when you declare it
by including the initial values in
braces after the Declaration
while declaring we could use curly
braces to set the values inside it
for example in this array of size 6 the
element 2 is at 0 index 5 is at one
index one is at 2 index and so on
if we don't mention the size of array
then the array will only be large enough
to hold the elements added within the
curly braces
other than this we can set the value
after the Declaration by assigning the
element to the array using its index
like array of 0 equal to 5
here we are assigning 5 to index 0 and
array of 1 equal to 7 here we are
assigning 7 to index 1 and same goes for
the array of 2. now let's do some
examples on array to understand them
better we'll do these examples on our
code editor that is vs code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now we'll make a new file
and let's name that file as
array.cppu
array1.cp
now we'll do a basic example in which we
have to print
the elements of array
so let's start first of all we'll write
the header file
[Music]
Dash include irstream
foreign
Spades standard
[Music]
I will write into Main
now we'll start by writing the data type
int now we'll write the array name that
is let's say coupon
and now the size of array
let's say 6.
now curly braces now inside these curly
braces we'll write those elements
let's say five
eight
seven
three
nine
one
so these are those elements and this is
a
array declaration
now
here int means the data type coupon is
the array Name six is the size of array
and
587391 are the elements of array
now after that we'll write the for loop
with four keyword
now we'll initialize I with 0
I less than 6 because it is the size of
array
now we'll increment I
now in this Loop all we have to do is to
print this array so how do we do that
so let's do c out
and inside the bracket we'll write I
so here we have printed the array inside
the loop and we have put I inside the
array bracket
now the loop will run from i 0 to 6 and
likewise all the elements from 5 to 1
will get printed so let's see
let's try to run this code
so this is our output
587391 so this is how we can print the
elements of an array
and if we want to print a particular
element from the array all we have to do
is to write the index number of that
element inside the bracket let's say if
we want to print 7
[Music]
all we have to do is to print its index
number that is 2.
now let's run this
see 777 it is because of the loop that
from i 0 to I6 that is why it is getting
printed six times
now if we remove the loop and try to
print it then it will get print only one
time
let's see
foreign
and this is what we want to print
now let's do another example
let's name this file
array2.cbd
foreign
all we have to do is to do the sum of
all the elements of the array
so let's start by writing our header
file
Dash include irstring
[Music]
Now using namespace STD
now we'll write into Main
now here first of all we'll declare a
variable sum and initialize it with 0.
[Music]
now we'll declare another variable n
and N will depict the size of the array
so first of all in order to scan array
first of all we have to scan the size of
it
so we'll scan and
foreign
[Music]
and inside the bracket we will mention n
because it is the size
[Music]
now we'll write for Loop
and we will initialize with I equals 0.
I less than n which is the size of array
and will increment I plus plus
we are writing for Loop here because we
want to scan the array and as in this
array there are more than one element so
that is why we need four loops
so now we will scan the array
we'll write C in
the name of array
and inside the bracket we'll write I
now here we have written I inside the
brackets because we want to take input
of elements from I equal to 0 to n which
is the size of area
no
we'll take another for Loop
now here we will write another for Loop
in which we are initializing I from 0 to
n and inside that for Loop we will do
the sum of the array
so we'll write
equals to zero
I less than n which is the size
now we will increment I plus plus
now inside this for Loop
we'll do the code we'll do the logic of
adding the elements of the array
we will write sum as we know that we
have already initialized sum with 0
we'll write sum equals to sum
Plus
array of fight
now for this statement sum equals to
some plus array of I we are adding each
value in the array one by one into the
sum which is initially 0. when I equals
to 0 then the sum will be equal to 0
plus array of 0 and this sum will keep
on getting stored inside the variable
sum
as our I increments our sum keeps on
storing the addition value
now we'll print this sum
outside the loop
we'll write C out
and we'll write sum is
okay
now we will write the sum variable
return
let me tell you return 0 is optional in
C plus plus basically return value is
exit status of the program and 0 is
considered as okay in C plus plus
compiler includes it automatically but
it's a good practice
here we forget to write the data type
now we'll try to run it
[Music]
foreign
so first of all we'll write the size
like
let's say six
now the elements of the array
let's say one
two three four
five and six
now we want to find the sum of these
elements
sum is 21 let's recheck 1 plus 2 equals
to 3 3 plus 3 equals 6 6 plus 4 10 10
plus 5 15 15 and 6 is 21 so this is our
right answer so this is another basic
example of array
so after this we'll do one example of
two Dimension array also
so let's make a new file
and we'll write the head file
let's name this file as
array3.cpp
now namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now we will declare a 2d array of three
rows and three columns with elements
inside it
three rows
and second bracket we'll write three
columns
now we'll write the curly braces
and another curly braces
this is the way to declare a 2d array
now to
seven
nine let's say
now again curly braces
one three
eight because we are creating a matrix
of 3 cross 3
that is why there are total nine
elements inside the array
so now we will create a nested for Loop
where the outer loop IE which is for the
rows of Matrix is initialized from 0 to
2.
we'll write int I equal to zero
now I Less Than 3
I in the space increment
now we will write inner for Loop J which
is for the column and we will initialize
it from 0 to 2 as well
we'll write for
int J equals 0
J Less Than 3
J plus plus
now we will print the array
in the first bracket we will mention I
that is the number of rows and in the
second bracket we will mention J that is
number of columns
and in order to add space
we will add
space in the output
now
outside the bracket we will mention
handle
shift the elements to the next line
after that we'll write it 0.
so this is our output
541279138 in The Matrix form that is why
I have used this space
to make the output look good and this
handle
so this is our output 541279138
so this is how we can print the elements
of a multi-dimensional array or two
dimensional array these were some basic
examples of array and in order to
understand these programs you must
practice more examples on it in this
session we will learn about sorting in C
plus plus so let's go ahead and have a
look at what we'll be covering today
we will learn what is sorting in C plus
plus then the categories of sorting
which are internal and external sorting
after that we will understand types of
sorting in C plus plus that are bubble
sort selection sort insertion sort and
quick sort and at last we will
understand sorting using C plus plus
Library
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so first is what is sorting in C plus
plus
sorting in C plus plus is a concept in
which the elements of array are
rearranged in a logical order
now this order can be from the lowest to
the highest or highest to the lowest
rearranging them in a sorted order helps
in dealing with many problems like
searching the maximum element or the
minimum element from an array of
elements
in C plus plus sorting is categorized
into two types that is internal sorting
and external sorting
so let's understand these in internal
sorting the data to be sorted is present
in the main memory
and the process of sorting will also
take place in the main memory itself
while in case of external sorting the
data is not always present in the main
memory because the data is large
so data is filled in the main memory in
small portions
so this is the difference between
internal sorting and external sorting
now coming to types of sorting in C plus
plus
there are various types of sorting in C
plus that are bubble sort selection sort
insertion sort and quick sort
select start with bubble sort
bubble sort is one of the easiest
sorting techniques in C plus plus
in this technique the comparisons are
done starting from the first two
elements
the adjacent elements are compared if
the element on the left is greater than
the element in the right then the
swapping is done
and it will proceed till the end of the
array
so first the comparison will start from
the first two elements that are 22 and
13. and as we know that 22 on the left
is greater than 13. so we will swap
these elements and make them 13 on the
left and 22 on the right
now it became
1322 5 7 11.
so now we will compare 22 which is at
index 1 with 5 that is at index 2. and
as 22 is greater than 5 we will swap
these elements as well
then again we will compare it with the
next element
and F22 is greater than that element as
well then we will swap them as well so
in this way round 1 of comparison is
complete as one of the element reached
its actual position
two more rounds of the comparisons will
occur till the array becomes sorted
it is because for n elements the number
of comparison are n minus 1.
so number of comparisons here would be 3
as the elements are 4 in numbers
now coming to selection sort
in this selection sort technique the
smallest element is fetched by comparing
itself with the rest of the elements
and is sorted at the first position of
the array
once the first element is sorted the
search for second minimum element begins
from the rest of the array and is
positioned at the second place
similarly one by one all the elements
are positioned like this
so this is selection sort now moving to
insertion sort technique
in this sorting technique the elements
are sorted by comparing the second
element with the first element
if the second element is smaller than
the first then we will swap it
after that we will compare the third
element with all the elements that are
before it
similarly it goes for the fourth element
and so on
once all the comparisons are done the
elements becomes sorted
as we can see in the figure
so this was insertion sort technique
next is quick sort technique or quick
sort algorithm
quick sort algorithm is one of the most
widely used algorithm and the most
efficient sorting algorithm
the quick sort algorithm follows a
divide and conquer approach
in this approach a pivot element is
selected and the array is partitioned
into two halves on the basis of this
pivot element
the elements that are smaller than the
pivot element are shifted to the left
side of it and the elements greater than
the pivot element are shifted to the
right side of it
after this both the left and the right
sub arrays are sorted and combined
for example
let's suppose we have six elements
5 15 1 8 22 and 6 and we want to sort
them using quick sort so first of all we
will select any pivot element let's say
6.
now we will divide the array to two sub
arrays based on the pivot element in
such a way that the element smaller than
the pivot element are on the left and
the elements greater than the pivot
element are on the right as you can see
in the figure element smaller than 6 are
on the left and elements greater than 6
are on the right
now we will sort both of these sub
arrays separately
we will select a pivot element from each
of the sub array
like we can see
from the first sub array we have
selected five and the second sub array
we have selected 15.
similarly if the element is less than
the pivot element then adjust it on the
left otherwise on the right
by doing this both the sub arrays will
become sorted and now we can combine
them to become a complete sorted array
so this is how quick sort algorithm
works
so as we have understood about the
Sorting technique now let's understand
how to sort using C plus plus Library
we can sort using the C plus plus
Library as well to use that Library
function we must include the hash
include algorithm header file
this function Compares each and every
element within the range
the syntax of function is sort then
within the brackets there will be the
starting iterator and the ending
iterator
and we must include this algorithm
header file with hash include which is a
preprocessor
so as we have understood about these
sorting algorithms so let's move to our
code editor that is vs code to do some
examples on this sorting algorithms
all right so this is our code editor and
here we'll do some examples of sorting
techniques so let's first of all create
a new file
and let's name it
sort 1 dot CPP
so let's add first of all the header
file hash include iostream
foreign
so first of all we will do an example of
bubble sort algorithm
and
now we'll create a main function inside
the main function we will create some
variables let's say int I int J and a
temporary variable
10.
after that we will declare an array ARR
and let's say the size of the array is
8.
and the elements of array are
let's say 3 1
5.
18 and
and 35.
so these are the elements of the array
now we will display these elements so
we'll
display a message unsorted array as we
know that these array elements are
unsorted so we will print the message
unsorted
with selection
all right
now
we'll
write the for Loop in I equals 0 that
runs from i 0 to I8 because you want to
print the array
I less than equal to 8 I less than 8
I plus plus
now here we will print the array
ARR
I so one by one all the elements will
get printed
and we'll add the slash T to add the
horizontal space between each element
all right
now
for space we will right we can write
handle
now we will write the logic for bubble
sort as we know in bubble sort the
swapping is done starting from the first
two elements and if the element on the
left is greater than the element on the
right then the swiping is done
so we'll do that
we'll write a for Loop
which runs from i0 to 8. and I equals 0
I less than 8.
I plus plus
and
the second for Loop would be
int J equals I plus 1
J less than 8
J plus plus
now I'll explain both of these loops
but before that let us just write the if
condition for swapping if ARR
I
is less than
ARR
J
oh
I Write the opposite of that which I
have to write and let's make it I yeah
if ARR of J is less than a r of I then
we'll do the swap so now I'll explain
this part
here when I is at 0 then J is at 0 plus
1 that is at index 1. so now comparison
will take place between element and
index 1 and element at index 0. if the
right element that is index 1 element is
smaller than the left element that is
index 0 element then swapping will take
place and similarly one by one each
element is compared with the next
element and it will proceed till the end
of the array
so now here we will write the swapping
logic
we will store the first variable into
the temporary variable
and then we will store the second
variable into array of I
then we'll again store
into array of J
the value holded by the temporary
variable all right so this is how
swiping is done
now all we need to do is to just print
the array elements because it
because we have to show the sorted
elements of the array so we'll first
display a message
sorted elements
all right
and then we'll use slash n as well
now here again we will use the for Loop
and
which runs from i 0 to i8
e less than 8.
I plus plus
and now we will print the elements of
the array of sorted array
just to add the horizontal space we can
write slash d
and now
after that return zero
let's save it and let's hope it will
work
so as we can see this is the unsorted
array 12315 18 10 7 35 and this is a
sorted elements of the array 1 3 5 7 10
12 18 35 so as you can see these
elements are sorted and using the slash
D we have added the space between each
of these elements
all right now let's do another example
so now let's do an example of insertion
sort first of all let's save it and
let's name it as
sort
2 dot CPP
now let's add the head files
hash include iostream
then write the namespace standard
then we'll start with the main function
into Main
now we'll write the variables like
and I int J and
num variables then the temp variable
temporary variable
and we'll also initialize the array
let's
make it 30 size
now we'll take the input from the user
so
right enter the elements
enter the number of elements first of
all
right
we'll take the input
as num
and then
we'll ask the user
to enter the
elements
all right
now
using for Loop
sorry
using for loop I
equals to zero
till I less than num
I plus plus
we will take the input
of the elements of the array one by one
so
num is the size of the array so one by
one all the elements will the user will
enter all the elements
all right after that
all right now we'll write the code for
insertion sort
please keep in mind in insertion sort
we start by comparing the second element
with the first element if the second
element is smaller than the first
element then we will swap it after that
we will compare the third element with
all the elements that are before it
similarly it goes for the fourth element
and so on
we can see this figure for reference and
now we'll start doing the code
we'll start by writing the for Loop
which starts from 0
till num minus 1.
less than I plus plus all right after
that
we will store the array in the temporary
variable
once it's done
then we'll write j i minus 1.
first of all we have copied the elements
of array to the temp variable then we
have set J equals to I minus 1 because
we have to compare it with the previous
element
and
all right now we'll write the while loop
Okay so
temp is less than a r r of
J plus 1
okay
now only J
and for termination J must be greater
than zero
all right let's
make them inside the brackets
all right now
first of all let's write the code then
and I'll explain the part
Arrow J plus 1
area of G
we will move this element forward and
then we'll write
J minus 1 will decrement it
then
you have to insert the element in this
place
all right
I'll explain this part in this part we
have copied the elements of array to the
temp variable first of all and then we
have set J equals to I minus 1 because
we have to compare it with one previous
element
and while in while loop we are checking
if the value of element prior to array
of J is more or less
if it is less than we moves the element
in order
set it to the right position
using array of J plus 1 equals to Temp
we are actually inserting the element in
a proper place
over the right position
we are validating that J remains greater
than equal to 0.
so this is how it's done and now we have
to print the elements
so now we have to print the sorted
element so we will write the message
will display the message
sorted
elements
and then using the for Loop
will display all the elements one by one
I plus plus
ARR
inside it will write I
and
will add some space
once it's done then all is left is to
write return zero
return zero now let's save it
once it is saved then now let's check
if it is running fine or not
as we can see enter the number of
elements in the array let's say there
are five elements
right
eight
one
four
nine
two
all right eight one four nine two so
our output is wrong let's check
I where it is
I less than equal to
this is the problem let's save it
and let's check it once more
five
now
eight five seven
two
six
eight two five six seven
all right now I get it actually we are
checking from the first element so we
have to start with the first index
now let's save it
and try one more time
and five nine
five eight
two
and let's say 12.
2 5 8 9 12. so finally our output is
correct
because of some logical mistakes our
output was getting wrong but now we
finally can see that two five eight nine
twelve the elements of the array are
finally sorted and this is how you can
do insertion sort
now after this we'll do another example
all right now let's do an example of
selection sort
let's name it as sort 3.
CBB so let's understand the selection
sorting Technique One More Time in this
technique the smallest element is
fetched by comparing itself with the
rest of the element and is sorted at the
first position of the array
after the first element is positioned
the search for the second element begins
from the rest of the array and is
positioned and the second place
similarly all other elements are
positioned like this as we can see in
the figure
now let's do its practical
implementation
so let's start by adding the header
files
hash include iostream
then we'll write the username space
standard
now we'll start with the main function
all right so first of all we'll declare
some variables like int I
and J
and num variable
then
a variable p
and a temporary variable temp
and we also need a minimum variable
we'll name it min
and now we will declare the array
let's make it of size 10 and yeah
now
we will display a message saying that
enter the number of elements
we'll write enter
the number of
elements
all right
now we will take the input
see in Num
now we'll ask them to enter the elements
so we'll write slash n
enter the
elements
all right now again we will use slation
once it's done now we can take the input
of the array
so we'll start with it and I equals 0 I
less than none
I plus plus
and now C in
array ARR
index I
[Music]
so yeah
now we can take the input from the user
and now we have to do the actual part
that is the selection sort we have to
sort the array using the selection sort
technique
so let's start
we'll write a for Loop and I equals 0
I less than num minus 1
.
I plus plus
inside this Loop we will store the value
of the first element of the array
Min equals ARR of I we are showing the
first element of array into this main
variable
so here we are storing the value now we
have to store the index
so the P variable which we have declared
and we are storing the
index I to this P variable
all right after that we have to use
another for Loop
where the actual comparisons begins
no we will write
J
equals to I plus 1
and
J less than num
J plus plus
now I'll explain you this for Loop
in this for Loop we are doing I plus 1
because here the comparison will take
place and the comparison will occur with
the preceding elements
so we have to do J equals to I Plus 1.
now we have to do inside this for Loop
we'll use a if condition so we'll write
if
minimum is greater than array of J
that if
that is
if any element is smaller than the
minimum element then that particular
element will be set as minimum element
so we'll do that we'll write Min equals
array of I array of J sorry
and we also have to change the index so
we'll assign the index of J to the P
earlier we have assigned the index I to
P but if that particular element is
smaller than the minimum element then we
also have to assign the index to p
now all we need to do is to swap
so now let's do the swapping part as
well
all right
so first of all the temporary variable
temp we will assign ARR of I
we have to swap Arrow of high and ARR of
P because the index J is assigned to p
and we all know how to do the swapping
if I
now we will
put the value of a error of P into a R5
foreign
goes to error of P so the swapping is
done here and now we have to just print
the sorted array
so now let's first of all display a
message saying that the sorted elements
are
right slash in
sorted elements
are
slashing again
Now using for Loop we will print all
those elements
equals zero
I less than n
um sorry I plus plus
all right now we will just print the
array
and now in order to give some space
we'll use the double quotes
now it's done
now return 0 will write
now everything is done now let's check
if it is working or not
it's done by our end so let's save it
and
let's try to run
enter the number of elements so okay so
let's add five
now five elements are eight
one five
sorry
one
five
three
seven
one three five seven eight as you can
see
these are the sorted elements and this
is correct
so this is how we can do the selection
sort this is our logic behind the
selection sort
you can try this example as well
all right now we'll do an example of
quick sort so first of all
let's create a new file
and name it as sort4.cpp
now as we know in quick sort follows the
divide and conquer algorithm so let's
have a look at it
as we know in quicksort our pivot
element is selected like here we have
selected six as a pivot element and then
the elements which are smaller than 6
are put on the left side and elements
which are greater than 6 are shifted to
the right side and similarly same thing
is done with the partitions or the sub
arrays and in the end when we combine we
get a sorted array so now practical
implementation so first of all we'll
start by creating a main function and
before that we'll add the header files
hash include myostream
and the namespace standard
all right now we'll start with the main
function
inside the main function we will
declare a variable num and another
variable I
and
declare an array ARR to size let's say
now we'll display a message saying that
enter the number of elements
all right now
here it is now we will take the input
from the user
num
now we'll display another message saying
that enter the elements
and now we'll use for Loop
to take the input from the user
I equals 0 I less than
num I plus plus
so inside this Loop C in and arri will
take the input from the user
user enters all the digits or the
elements now we will call a function
quick
and we'll pass the arguments array and
the starting index and the ending index
the starting index would be zero
and any index would be num minus 1 that
is size minus 1.
so this is where we are calling the
quick function and after that we can
display a message saying that
after sorting
the elements are
foreign
loop again
we can display the sorted array
afterwards
in add some space
yes
and
we'll write return zero so our main
function is done now all we need to do
is to make the quick function
all right so let's create this quick
function
quick
and it's data type would be void
quite quick and we'll pass the
the arguments all the parameters are
array and the starting index and the
ending in this
start
and end
so these are the parameters and inside
this quick function
will write the if condition that is if
start of the index is less than n that
is if the array element is more than one
then
here we will find the point of division
D and then there would be recursive
calls for the divided sub arrays for the
partitions
so now
we will make the division Point d
and now we'll call the function divide
and we'll pass the parameters array and
the starting index and the ending index
to this function as well
so here
D is the division point and by calling
this function we'll find this division
point yeah
after that we will do the recursive call
for the left sub array and the right sub
array
so let's do that
quick
array in starting index and ending index
but here ending index would be as it is
a sub array as it is the left sub array
so the division point is the point of
division so the ending index for the
left sub array would be D minus 1.
and similarly now again we'll call for
the right sub array
here's the starting index would be D
plus 1
and ending index would be
end
let me explain this part again
the first recursive call would be from
start
to D minus 1
and the second recursive call from is
from D plus 1 to the end
so these are the two sub arrays this is
the right sub array and this one is the
left sub array so D minus 1 is this
element and D plus 1 is this element
all right now we'll make this divide
function
and we have to make this divide function
above the quick function otherwise it
will show an error or if you don't want
to do that then you can do the forward
declaration but I'll prefer doing this
only
so
print is the data type divide is the
name
and now
end ARR
as we have passed the starting index
and the
sorry the starting index
and the ending index
all right
now inside this divide function first of
all we will set a pivot element
cool
so we'll do that ARR
we always we usually select the last
element as pivot element or you can
select the first element as well or any
random element so
now
we'll create another variable int index
and
will assign its start index now this
variable will keep the track of elements
in the array starting from all first
element and all these elements so
now
we'll use a for Loop and now we will do
the comparison with the pivot element so
inside the for Loop int I equals 0
sorry int I equals start because we'll
start from the first element so I equals
start I less than and we will not use
less than equal to we'll use I less than
n because we don't want to include the
pivot element
so that is why we'll use I less than end
and now I plus plus
all right
all right now inside this for Loop we
will create if condition now in this
condition if the array of I
is less than the pivot element then we
will shift it towards the left then
we'll do the swapping
arri
is less than
pivot
then
temporary variable temp and we all know
how to do the swapping
so we'll do that
arri index
please note that index is storing the
start and pivot is storing the end
to keep in mind that now
ARR
index
this temporary variable
now we will increment this index plus
plus because this index plus plus will
do the further comparison with pivot
element
so if
that particular element is smaller than
the pivot element then it will move to
the left side otherwise on the right
side
all right now it's done now the only
thing left is the positioning of the
pivot element
and to do that because we have to find
the partitioning point so we have to
position the pivot element at its proper
place so for that we'll use the
temporary variable again
and
ARR
and index
then
we'll swap it
with index
so here we are done with the swapping
now we have found the partitioning point
so we will return the index now the
pivot is at its proper position now all
the elements on the left side of the
pivot element are smaller than that and
all the elements on the right side of it
are greater than that
now let's try to save it and run it
I hope it works
there are some errors let's check
all right
all right let's do it
and this one is
this one is extra
all right now let's save it and run it
enter the number of elements let's say
we have entered five not that place
five elements
three one nine five
seven
one three five seven nine
so this is our sorted elements of the
array and we have done it using the
quick sort method or the algorithm
and this is our code
and this is a logic behind the quick
sort method
you can also practice this quick sort
algorithm it is one of the most
efficient sorting algorithm
and we have done the examples of bubble
sort selection sort insertion sort and
quick sort you can practice them all
today's topic is pointers in C plus plus
and in today's session we will learn
about what is a pointer reference and D
reference operator
then declaration and initialization of a
pointer
then there is pointer arithmetic and
after that we'll go through pointers and
functions pointers and arrays and at
last we have arrows open so let's go to
our first topic that is what is a
pointer pointer can be defined as a
variable that contains the address of
another variable it basically stores the
memory address which means it points to
an address of a particular value
and like a regular variable pointers
have a data type also now coming to
reference and D reference operators
reference operator or address of
operator is defined as that operator
which is used to get the address of the
variable
it can be easily obtained by preceding
the name of the variable within
Ampersand sign
now D reference operator D reference
operator basically Returns the content
stored in the variable pointed by the
specified pointer
for example if we write asterisk a then
it will return the value of variable
pointed by a now let's see how to
declare and initialize a pointer to
declare a pointer first of all we will
write the data type
after that we will write the name of the
variable with an asterisk sign for
example int asterisk sign a float
asterisk B care asterisk C
suppose if we want to store the address
into a pointer then we will write int
that is the data type then PTR that is
the name of the pointer
with an asterisk sign equals to a
variable a with Ampersand sign which
means PTR will contain the address of
the variable a
now moving to a pointer arithmetic
C plus plus allows us to perform
addition and subtraction operations on
pointers a pointer is basically an
address that is it's a numeric value
therefore operations like addition
subtraction can easily be done on
pointers
there are four types of arithmetic
operations that can be used in pointers
that is increment Operator decrement
Operator addition and subtraction
each time a pointer is incremented by
one it points to the memory location of
the next element
but if the pointer is an integer pointer
its value on PTR plus plus would
increment by 4 bytes because of the size
of in data type
for example assume an integer pointer
with current value of 10.
now after the increment its value would
be 14 instead of 11 because int is of 4
bytes now let's learn about pointers and
functions
like a normal variable has an address
similarly every function has an address
also and we can easily access the
function using its reference or address
only if we know the address of the
function
function pointers are similar to that of
normal pointers when pointers are passed
to the function the address of actual
arguments in the calling function is
copied into the formal arguments of the
called function
and this is the Syntax for a declaration
of function pointer
here int is the return type and
parenthesis around function pointer
tells the compiler that it is a pointer
2 function
and after this they are argument lists
now let's discuss pointers and arrays
arrays and pointers are very closely
related to each other and both of them
are objects
when an array gets declared the compiler
assigns a continuous block of memory so
that all the elements of an array can be
stored in the memory
and C plus plus treats the name of the
array as a pointer that contains the
address of first element
which is known as Base address so
basically array name is the Base address
of the array
and if we have to sign the address of
first element of array in a variable X
then instead of writing x equal to
Ampersand array of 0 we can simply write
the name of the array only now moving to
the last topic that is array of pointers
like in Array we can store similar type
of elements it is same in case of array
of pointers but the only difference is
instead of storing the elements the
address of similar type of element is
stored
in other words it stores the pointers
which point to the similar data type
and this is the syntax first is data
type then name of array with an asterisk
sign then in the brackets it is the size
of array now let's do some examples in
our code editor that is vs code if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
here we will do one example of pointer
to understand reference and D reference
operator
we will print the values of variable and
the address of that variable also and it
will give us an idea about reference and
reference operator
let's start first of all we'll make a
new file
and name this file as
pointer1.cpp
so first of all we will import the
header file
stream
now we will include namespace template
after that we'll make int Main
and now we will declare a variable
well
and assign it a value let's say 105.
now we will declare a pointer variable
PTR
now we will store the address of the
variable well into the pointer variable
so we will write PTR equals
Ampersand well
now
will display a message
before printing well variable we'll
display a message saying
value is
value of Val is
now let's see what is the value of PTR
for that we will have to print PTR also
and we'll write
foreign
PTR
is
now we will print the pointer variable
PTR also although the value of Val and
PTR would be same but in order to check
we will print that also
so we'll write
C out
value of
explicit PTR
is
now as we have printed variable Val
PTR and asterisk PTR
so now let's check all these values
next question will be right return zero
now let's check all these values
here we can see value of variable Val is
105.
and the value of PTR is this this is
actually the address
and the value of pointer variable PTR is
105 as we know that the value of VL and
the pointer variable is same because we
have assigned this value the address of
variable well to PTR
and then the D reference operator
as we know Returns the actual content of
the variable so that is why the value of
variable well gets printed when we print
the pointer variable PTR
and the address over here
is the address of the Val variable which
we are assigning to the PTR
so that is why this address is getting
printed
now we'll do another example let's name
it
pointer 2.0 CPP
now we'll include the header files
mesh include a stream
after that using namespace standard
so here we have an example of arithmetic
operations in C plus plus so first of
all we'll write int Main
foreign
now here we will take four variables and
two pointers
so let's do it
and num1
command number two
and
sum equals zero and in sub
equals 0 will initialize it with zero
now I will declare the pointers
ptr1
ptr2
so let's take input of the required
variables num1 and num2 and after that
we'll do some mathematic operations on
them
so let's just write
first we'll display a message
enter two numbers
enter
two numbers
now we'll take the input
after this we will store the address of
num1 and num2 into ptr1 and ptr2
respectively let's do it
ptr1
ampersand
number one
ptr2
Ampersand number two
now we will increment pointer ptr1 and
ptr2
we'll do in a bracket and we'll use D
reference operator also
ptr1 plus plus
the reference operator
etr2
plus plus
here we are using D reference operator
because we want to increment the value
only
and as we can see we have used increment
operator so by incrementing ptr1 and
ptr2 the values of num1 and num2 will
increment and after that we will print
those values
so let's do it
before printing we'll just print a
message
after increment
foreign
ptr1
and line
now ptr2
now we will do the sum of these
incremented values so we will write some
equals
D reference operator PTR one
Plus
D reference operator ptr2
now we will simply print it
write addition
and we'll print some variable
which we have already initialized as
zero earlier
and we'll write and line
so this will give us the sum of the
incremented values of num1 and num2
now let's talk about decrementing the
value of pointers using decrement
operator
hereby using this operator the value of
the ptr1 and ptr2 gets decremented so
let's start
and write
document ptr1
minus minus
that is the decrement operator
now
ptr2
and S minus
now we will write
after decrement
the values of ptr1 and ptr2
so we'll display a message saying
after decrement
now we will print ptr1 and ptr2
this will display the values of ptr1 and
ptr2 after decrement
and at last we will find the subtraction
of 2.
so we'll write sub
decrement operator ptr1 minus decrement
operator ptr2
and C out
will display first subtraction we'll
write subtraction
then we'll write the variable sub
let's see how it before that I think
before going to mention the T reference
operator
while printing
we have to mention this because we want
to print the values
the reference operator
and let's put some space over here
now let's try
enter two numbers so let's say We'll
enter four
and five
as you can see we have entered four and
five after increment it becomes five and
six and on addition it becomes 11 after
decrement it becomes 4 and 5 again
then 4 minus 5 that is equal to minus 1
so this is the right answer and this is
how it's done this was the basic example
of arithmetic operations in pointers
now let's do another example
name this file as pointer three dot CPP
now we will include the header files
hash include
by your stream
using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now we will do an example of pointer and
arrays in which all we have to do is to
print an array with the help of pointers
so let's start
first of all we will declare a pointer
now we'll declare an array
named a r r a y
and let's add some elements inside it
five
[Music]
sorry 20
7.
fourth six
I think these are seven elements
now we will assign array ARR to pointer
PTR so we'll write PTR equals ARR
after that we'll run a loop from I equal
to 0 to I less than 7 because we want to
iterate array elements so let's write
for Loop
and I equals 0 I less than 7 I plus plus
now we will display
using D reference operator with pointer
because we want to display the values
that is why we have used the reference
operator
now we'll do PTR plus plus
we have used PTR plus plus because we
want the pointer to move to the next
position after each iteration
and endl will help to print the output
in the next line after each iteration
so after this we'll write
return 0.
and let's try to run it
I think there is some error
yeah
namespace
now let's again try to run it
um instead of array we have used ARR
hope it works now
here it is
5 17 20 7 9 4 6. so these are our array
Elements which we want to print so this
is how we can print the array elements
with the help of pointer
so these were some basic examples of
pointers in C plus plus in this session
we will learn about this pointer in C
plus plus
so let's go ahead and have a look at
what we'll be covering today
so in this session we will cover topics
like what is this pointer
then we will have a look at the syntax
of this pointer
then we will understand the working of
this pointer and after that we will
learn how to access the executing object
using this keyword
and we will also learn about the
features of this pointer
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so first topic is what is this pointer
in C plus plus this is a keyword that is
used to represent an object that invokes
the member functions
it automatically points to the object
for which the object is being called
or in other words this keyword points to
the current instance or object of the
class
for example let us suppose we have a
local variable of same name as that of
the data member and we want to assign
the value of a local variable to the
data member but having the same name
would create a problem
so in this type of case we use this
pointer
this keyword tells the compiler that we
are referring to objects data members
now let's learn about the syntax of this
pointer
the Syntax for refereeing class variable
or instance variable would be this
keyword then Arrow operator with class
variable equal to local variable value
and the Syntax for reference to current
object of class would be this with
asterisk sign or D reference operator
sign
now let's understand working of this
pointer
that this keyword represents the address
of current instance of the class
that this pointer acts as an implicit
parameter to all the member functions
now implicit parameters are similar to
normal parameters
the only difference is these parameters
are passed silently to the functions
that is it is passed as a hidden
argument and is automatically passed to
the member function when it is called
now let's learn how to access the
executing object
as we can see in the example we have
created an object obj of class o and
with the help of this object we have
called this function display in which we
are printing the address of the object